there's a quote from one of my english
teacher named uh
mr fisk
he had a great quote that said rest at
the end not in the middle
and that's something i always live by
i'm not going to rest i'm going to keep
on pushing now there's a lot of answers
that i don't have
even questions that i don't have but i'm
just going to keep going it's going to
keep going and i'll figure these things
out as you go
i had a summer where i played basketball
when i was like 10 or 11 years old
and here i come
playing and i don't score one point
the entire summer not one how did you
not score because i was terrible not a
free throw not a nothing not a lucky
shot not a breakaway layup zero points
and i remember crying about it being
upset about it my father just gave me a
hug and said listen
whether you score zero score 60 i'm
gonna love you no matter what wow now
that is the most important thing that
you can say to a child
because from there i was like okay that
gives me all the confidence in the world
to fail
i have the security there
but to hell with that i'm scoring 60.
let's go right right right from there i
just went to work i just i stayed with
him i kept practicing kept practicing
kept practice i think that's when the
idea of understanding a long-term view
became important
because i wasn't going to catch these
kids in a week i wasn't going to catch
them in a year
right so that's when i sat down and said
okay this is going to take some thought
i think the best way to prove your your
value is to work
it's to learn is to absorb
to be a sponge
right you always want to outwork
your potential you know as hard as you
believe you can work you can work harder
than that i mean you got to figure it
out if you really have an obsession to
figure it out you will figure it out
right and every puzzle is constructed
differently
all right ai situation when he came into
the league was different than mine
mike's situation in chicago was
different than mine right everybody has
a different puzzle man you just got to
figure out your own puzzle you know
basketball for me
was the most important thing
so everything i saw
whether it was tv shows whether it was
books i read
people i talked to everything was done
to try to learn how to become a better
basketball player everything everything
and so when you have that point of view
then literally the world becomes your
library to help you to become better at
your craft you're out running on the
track working out and you start talking
to yourself saying man my knee is really
sore right now
maybe i'm
maybe i'm doing too much may i need to
back off you know
man my lungs are burning am i maybe i
can just slow down here i'll do like an
extra two sets tomorrow you know it'll
be okay yeah right that sort of stuff
yes like that stuff's dangerous yes and
that's you just gotta say you know what
i'm not negotiating with myself yeah the
deal was already made deal was made when
i set out at the beginning of the summer
and said this is the training plan i'm
doing
i sign that contract with myself i'm
doing it
you know throughout the that process
you'll start talking to yourself like
man i gotta i think i need to maybe if
we nope you gotta set the example this
this is another obstacle
this obstacle cannot define me it's not
gonna [ __ ] me it's not gonna be
responsible
for me stepping away for the game that i
love i'm going to step away on my own
terms
and that's when a decision was made that
you know what i'm doing it
you have those conversations with
yourself
are you able to negotiate your way out
of
you know that little
you know voice telling you it's not that
important or does that little voice get
the best of you
i think that's what separates people who
are going to do great things versus
people who don't or people that do great
things but in an inconsistent way you
know the idea is a very simple one and
you know the mamba mentality simply
means
trying to be the best version of
yourself
that's what the mentality means it means
every day you know you're trying to
become better and it's a constant quest
it's an infinite quest to me the
mentality is a really simple one in the
sense that the confidence comes from
preparation
you know so when the game's on the line
i'm not asking myself to do something
that i haven't done thousands of times
before
so when i prepare i know what i'm
capable of doing i know what i'm
comfortable doing and i know what i'm
not comfortable doing just piece by
piece and it's the consistency of the
work which
monday get better tuesday get better
wednesday get better and you do that
over a period of time you know not like
one month or two months i mean it's
three four five six seven eight nine ten
years and then you you know you can get
to where you want to go it's really just
a journey of
evolution every day it's just constant
improvement constant curiosity
constantly getting better the results
don't really matter
uh it's the figuring out that matters
every person has the ability to put one
foot in front of the other so you look
at every challenge at every step
and uh that's how you're able to
be resilient and come back from these
things
you have to sit and ask yourself what is
truly gonna get you up in the morning
it's gonna keep you up at night and um
you know when you find what that answer
is you stay true to that if you got to
get up every single morning remind
yourself how hard you need to work you
probably need to choose a different
profession
you know because that shouldn't be there
because i wake up in the morning excited
to get to it you know if i'm not
training i'm missing it
i'm not watching the game of basketball
i miss it you know there's no place i'd
rather be and if you have that feeling
then you're truly doing what god has put
you on this earth to do
make sure that your dreams always stay
pure
so it's not a matter of pushing beyond
your limitations or expectations it's
really a matter of protecting your
dreams protecting your imagination
that's really the key and when you do
that then the world just seems
limitless obsessiveness just comes from
something that you love like you really
love it you'll go through fire for it
you know you'll go through the ups and
downs with it and you'll just keep at it
because you love it so much you know but
what stays is how do you use your
passion and use that to inspire somebody
else to create their passion and then
how can they pass that on to the next
person
that is true success
the greatest fear that we face is
ourselves
actually you know i think it's uh
it's not anything that's external or
anything that's superficial i think the
greatest fear you face is yourself
because
you know we all have dreams and it's
very scary sometimes to accept
the dream that you have and it's scarier
still to say okay i want that
it's scary because you're afraid that if
you put your heart and soul into it and
you fail then how are you going to feel
about yourself
right so being fearless means putting
yourself out there
and going for it no matter what go for
it not for anybody else
but for yourself what i try to do is
just try to be still
and understand that things
come and go
emotions come and go
the important thing is to
accept them all
to embrace them all
and then you can choose to do with them
which you want versus being
controlled by emotion
before you start a game how can you lock
in and get into that mental space
where nothing else matters you're
completely locked in and focused on what
you're trying to accomplish as an
athlete out here the noise of the crowd
doesn't matter
whether you're cheering or bullying
doesn't matter you're just completely
locked in you have to dance beautifully
in the box that you are comfortable
dancing in so like everybody's box is
different
my box was to be extremely ambitious
within the sport of basketball your box
is different than mine right every kid
here has their own box but it doesn't
mean that your box isn't as beautiful as
mine what are you comfortable being what
it is that what is it that you want to
do with your life and once you have that
then you try to live it to the best of
your ability i made a promise to myself
from that day that i was going to work
that hard every single day so that when
i do retire i have no regrets
and that was the most important thing
for me is to leave no stone unturned
get better every single day and if i
live that way then over time
you know i'd have something that was
beautiful when i retired i didn't want
to have to say
i wish i would have done more
i don't want that it's just a matter of
what's important to you and what's
important to you for for whatever reason
you know i i felt like um i didn't feel
good about myself if i wasn't
doing everything i could to be the best
version of myself
if i felt like i left anything on the
table
um it would eat away at me i wouldn't be
able to look myself in the mirror
and so the reason why i can retire now
and be completely comfortable about it
because i know that i've done
everything i could to be the best
basketball player i could be
getting to know people on a personal
level what are their fears what are
their insecurities right what are their
dreams and ambitions desires those sorts
of things you come to understand that
about a person then you can help them
reach the best version of themselves we
work through this stuff together and
like
you know as a leader you got to be able
to take the good with the bad man you
can't just because the ship's sinking
all of a sudden i'm gonna jump off and
swim to another ship like that you don't
do that
right you can win championships in front
of everybody
then you can miss the playoffs in front
of everybody you got to be able to take
both sides of it